Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca|||加拿大的油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司联合起来，在迈向净零排放的道路上大步迈进。投资于技术和创新。每桶石油的排放量平均已减少 22%。与政府合作创造和保护就业机会。开发世界上最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们在多条路径上取得了进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In the early hours of Saturday, March 16, 1996, John Haggard awoke to the acrid odor of something burning. It was around 1.20am and the 17-year-old had only been asleep for a couple of hours. John was at home with these two younger brothers, 15-year-old Lawrence and 12-year-old Dennis.
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In the early hours of Saturday, March 16, 1996, John Haggard awoke to the acrid odor of something burning. It was around 1.20am and the 17-year-old had only been asleep for a couple of hours. John was at home with these two younger brothers, 15-year-old Lawrence and 12-year-old Dennis.|||我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您觉得随时需要支持，请联系当地的危机干预中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目简介。1996年3月16日，星期六清晨，约翰·哈加德被一股刺鼻的烧焦味熏醒。当时大约是凌晨1点20分，这名17岁的少年才刚睡着几个小时。约翰当时在家，和他的两个弟弟在一起，分别是15岁的劳伦斯和12岁的丹尼斯。
The boy's mother, Janet, had gone out the previous evening to celebrate a relative's birthday. The outing was a rare treat for Janet, a single mother who spent most of her time caring for her sons. As the oldest of his siblings, John was in charge until her return. As John awoke, he saw heavy curtains of smoke wafting through his bedroom. He scrambled out of bed and rushed out the door. The smoke was rising up the staircase from the ground floor below. It was accompanied by a noise that sounded like heavy breathing or snoring. John headed downstairs and followed the smoke to its origin point, the living room.
The boy's mother, Janet, had gone out the previous evening to celebrate a relative's birthday. The outing was a rare treat for Janet, a single mother who spent most of her time caring for her sons. As the oldest of his siblings, John was in charge until her return. As John awoke, he saw heavy curtains of smoke wafting through his bedroom. He scrambled out of bed and rushed out the door. The smoke was rising up the staircase from the ground floor below. It was accompanied by a noise that sounded like heavy breathing or snoring. John headed downstairs and followed the smoke to its origin point, the living room.|||男孩们的母亲珍妮特前一天晚上出去庆祝亲戚的生日了。对于珍妮特这位把大部分时间都花在照顾儿子身上的单亲妈妈来说，这次外出是一次难得的犒劳。作为兄弟姐妹中的老大，在珍妮特回来之前，约翰负责照看家里。当约翰醒来时，他看到浓烟如厚重的帘幕般在卧室里飘荡。他从床上爬起来，冲出了门。浓烟正从底楼的楼梯向上升腾。伴随着浓烟的，是一种听起来像沉重呼吸声或打鼾的声音。约翰下楼顺着浓烟找到了源头——客厅。
He entered the darkened room and saw his 15-year-old brother Lawrence lying on the floor in his underwear. His head was bruised and bleeding, as was his shoulder. Lawrence didn't stir, but John could hear his brother's labored breaths. A fire crackled at Lawrence's feet and was spreading up his legs. John tried to drag Lawrence out of the room, but his unconscious body was too heavy. He managed to pull Lawrence far enough away from the fire, then rushed to get a bucket of water. He poured it out over Lawrence's burning face. He then pulled Lawrence out of the room.
He entered the darkened room and saw his 15-year-old brother Lawrence lying on the floor in his underwear. His head was bruised and bleeding, as was his shoulder. Lawrence didn't stir, but John could hear his brother's labored breaths. A fire crackled at Lawrence's feet and was spreading up his legs. John tried to drag Lawrence out of the room, but his unconscious body was too heavy. He managed to pull Lawrence far enough away from the fire, then rushed to get a bucket of water. He poured it out over Lawrence's burning face. He then pulled Lawrence out of the room.|||他走进了漆黑的房间，看到15岁的弟弟劳伦斯只穿着内衣躺在地板上。他的头部和肩膀都有淤青和流血。劳伦斯一动不动，但约翰能听到弟弟艰难的呼吸声。劳伦斯的脚边燃起了一团火，并正顺着他的双腿蔓延开来。约翰试图把劳伦斯拖出房间，但他昏迷的身体太重了。他设法把劳伦斯拉到离火源足够远的地方，然后冲去拿了一桶水。他把水泼在劳伦斯燃烧的脸上。然后他把劳伦斯拉出了房间。
John tried to drag Lawrence out of the room, but his unconscious body was too heavy. He managed to pull Lawrence far enough away from the fire, then rushed to get a bucket of water. He poured it out over Lawrence's burning feet, dousing the flames. As he tended to his badly injured brother, John noticed the front door to the house was open. He could see out to the street, but no one was around. John sprinted back upstairs and entered the bedroom that Lawrence shared with their youngest brother, 12-year-old Dennis. The room was filled with smoke, but Dennis appeared sound asleep in his bed. John roused him and told him that Lawrence was hurt downstairs.
John tried to drag Lawrence out of the room, but his unconscious body was too heavy. He managed to pull Lawrence far enough away from the fire, then rushed to get a bucket of water. He poured it out over Lawrence's burning feet, dousing the flames. As he tended to his badly injured brother, John noticed the front door to the house was open. He could see out to the street, but no one was around. John sprinted back upstairs and entered the bedroom that Lawrence shared with their youngest brother, 12-year-old Dennis. The room was filled with smoke, but Dennis appeared sound asleep in his bed. John roused him and told him that Lawrence was hurt downstairs.|||约翰试图把劳伦斯拖出房间，但他昏迷的身体太重了。他设法把劳伦斯拉到离火源足够远的地方，然后冲去拿了一桶水。他把水泼在劳伦斯燃烧的双脚上，扑灭了火焰。在照顾重伤的弟弟时，约翰注意到屋子的前门是开着的。他能看到外面的街道，但四周空无一人。约翰飞奔回楼上，走进了劳伦斯和他们最小的弟弟、12岁的丹尼斯合住的卧室。房间里充满了烟雾，但丹尼斯在床上似乎睡得很熟。约翰叫醒了他，告诉他劳伦斯在楼下受伤了。
At around this time, Janet Haggart returned home after her night out. Upon discovering Lawrence's bloodied and burnt body, she let out a deafening shriek and began wailing loudly. John had to phone triple-nine emergency from the bathroom so that the operator could hear him over his mother's distress. Paramedics and the police arrived at the Haggart home within minutes. Lawrence was still alive, but unresponsive. He was rushed to hospital. The brutal attack was as inexplicable as it was shocking. Lawrence was popular and well-liked, and got on well with his brothers and mother. The family of four lived in the small town of Larbert in the Falkirk Council area of Scotland.
At around this time, Janet Haggart returned home after her night out. Upon discovering Lawrence's bloodied and burnt body, she let out a deafening shriek and began wailing loudly. John had to phone triple-nine emergency from the bathroom so that the operatorcould hear him over his mother's distress. Paramedics and the police arrived at the Haggart home within minutes. Lawrence was still alive, but unresponsive. He was rushed to hospital. The brutal attack was as inexplicable as it was shocking. Lawrence was popular and well-liked, and got on well with his brothers and mother. The family of four lived in the small town of Larbert in the Falkirk Council area of Scotland.|||大约在这个时候，珍妮特·哈加德结束了夜间的出行回到了家. 在发现劳伦斯血迹斑斑、被烧焦的身体后，她发出了一声震耳欲聋的尖叫，并开始放声大哭。约翰不得不躲在卫生间里拨打999紧急电话，这样接线员才能在母亲悲痛的哭喊声中听到他的声音。急救人员和警察在几分钟内赶到了哈加德的家中。劳伦斯还活着，但没有反应。他被紧急送往医院。这起残酷的袭击既令人震惊又莫名其妙。劳伦斯人缘很好，很受欢迎，和他的兄弟们以及母亲相处得很好。这四口之家住在苏格兰福尔柯克议会区的拉伯特小镇上。
Their home was one of dozens of matching two-story, semi-detached houses on Glenburvey Drive. Cramped and box-like, the houses were packed in a large estate characterised by narrow roads, including closed rear gardens and front doors a few metres away from the street. Lawrence was named after his father, who went by the nickname Larry. By 1996, Janet and Larry Haggart had been separated for three years. While the couple's sons lived with their mother, they remained close to their father. Larry lived four miles west of Larbert in the village of Dunney Pace, where he worked as a painter and decorator. He stayed nearby to his boys and maintained a close relationship with them.
Their home was one of dozens of matching two-story, semi-detached houses on Glenburvey Drive. Cramped and box-like, the houses were packed in a large estate characterised by narrow roads, including closed rear gardens and front doors a few metres away from the street. Lawrence was named after his father, who went by the nickname Larry. By 1996, Janet and Larry Haggart had been separated for three years. While the couple's sons lived with their mother, they remained close to their father. Larry lived four miles west of Larbert in the village of Dunney Pace, where he worked as a painter and decorator. He stayed nearby to his boys and maintained a close relationship with them.|||他们的家是格伦伯维大道上几十栋配套的双层半独立房屋之一。这些房子狭窄如方盒，挤在一个大型住宅区里，道路狭窄，后花园封闭，前门距离街道只有几米远。劳伦斯的命名源于他的父亲，他父亲的昵称是拉里。到1996年，珍妮特和拉里·哈加德已经分居三年了。虽然这对夫妇的儿子们和母亲住在一起，但他们与父亲的关系依然密切。拉里住在拉伯特以西四英里处的邓尼佩斯村，他在那里从事油漆工和粉刷匠的工作。他住在离儿子们很近的地方，并与他们保持着密切的联系。
Lawrence inherited more than just his father's name. He also shared his passion and skill for football or soccer. Years prior, Larry Haggart had played for the semi-professional football club Allower Athletic. It was clear from a young age that Lawrence would follow in his father's footsteps. In Scotland, professional football clubs offered schoolboy forms to promising young players between the ages of nine and sixteen. Chosen Boys received special training with a chance to play for their respective clubs later on down the track. In 1995, Lawrence's dream came true when he signed Schoolboy Forms for Celtic, an elite Scottish football club.
Lawrence inherited more than just his father's name. He also shared his passion and skill for football or soccer. Years prior, Larry Haggart had played for the semi-professional football club Allower Athletic. It was clear from a young age that Lawrence would follow in his father's footsteps. In Scotland, professional football clubs offered schoolboy forms to promising young players between the ages of nine and sixteen. Chosen Boys received special training with a chance to play for their respective clubs later on down the track. In 1995, Lawrence's dream came true when he signed Schoolboy Forms for Celtic, an elite Scottish football club.|||劳伦斯继承的不仅仅是父亲的名字。他还继承了父亲对足球的热情和球技。几年前，拉里·哈加德曾效力于半职业足球俱乐部阿洛厄竞技。劳伦斯很小的时候就注定要走父亲的老路，这是显而易见的。在苏格兰，职业足球俱乐部为9到16岁有前途的年轻球员提供学童合同。入选的男孩会接受专门的训练，并有机会在未来为各自的俱乐部效力。1995年，当劳伦斯与苏格兰精英足球俱乐部凯尔特人签下学童合同时，他的梦想成真了。
The placement meant a lot to the team. His great-uncle had played for Celtic, and it was the team Lawrence had supported his entire life. It was expected that he would sign professional forms with the club in December 1996, taking him one step closer to a career as a star footballer. Lawrence was so talented that he was selected for Scotland's international under-15 squad. Three days before he was attacked in his home, he'd made his on-field debut against Belgium. His team won. Although it was anticipated that Lawrence would go on to achieve glory on the football field, he had a backup plan in case things didn't work out. He would pursue his passion for sport by becoming a physical education teacher. As Lawrence underwent life-saving surgery, his home was cordoned off as a crime scene. Attending police officers were quickly joined by forensic scientists and members of Central Scotland's Fire Brigade.
The placement meant a lot to the team. His great-uncle had played for Celtic, and it was the team Lawrence had supported his entire life. It was expected that he would sign professional forms with the club in December 1996, taking him one step closer to a career as a star footballer. Lawrence was so talented that he was selected for Scotland's international under-15 squad. Three days before he was attacked in his home, he'd made his on-field debut against Belgium. His team won. Although it was anticipated that Lawrence would go on to achieve glory on the football field, he had a backup plan in case things didn't work out. He would pursue his passion for sport by becoming a physical education teacher. As Lawrence underwent life-saving surgery, his home was cordoned off as a crime scene. Attending police officers were quickly joined by forensic scientists and members of Central Scotland's Fire Brigade.|||这个名额对这支球队意义重大。他的曾叔祖父曾效力于凯尔特人队，这也是劳伦斯一生支持的球队。预计他将在1996年12月与该俱乐部签下职业合同，这使他离成为一名球星的职业生涯更近了一步。劳伦斯极具天赋，入选了苏格兰U15国家队。在他家中遭遇袭击的三天前，他在对阵比利时的比赛中首次亮相。他的球队赢了。尽管人们预计劳伦斯将在足球场上取得辉煌的成就，但如果事情不顺利，他也有一个备用计划。他将通过成为一名体育老师来追求自己对体育的热情。在劳伦斯接受救命手术的同时，他的家也被拉起警戒线作为犯罪现场。执勤警员很快与法医科学家和苏格兰中部消防局的成员会合。
Charles Collier was a divisional officer with the Fire Brigade. He examined the charred remnants of the pyre that had been lit by Lawrence's feet in the living room. It was made from a pile of clothes, a checked shirt, a pair of jeans, and two boots. It appeared as though Lawrence's attacker had dragged his body to the spot after the initial attack. The carpet underneath featured a scorch mark in the shape of a semicircle. Officer Collier could tell it had been deliberately lit, but couldn't find any trace of an accelerant. A second fire had also spread from a nearby couch. A duvet was crumpled on top of it. It appeared as though a lighter was held up to it, after which flames had fanned upwards.
Charles Collier was a divisional officer with the Fire Brigade. He examined the charred remnants of the pyre that had been lit by Lawrence's feet in the living room. It was made from a pile of clothes, a checked shirt, a pair of jeans, and two boots. It appeared as though Lawrence's attacker had dragged his body to the spot after the initial attack. The carpet underneath featured a scorch mark in the shape of a semicircle. Officer Collier could tell it had been deliberately lit, but couldn't find any trace of an accelerant. A second fire had also spread from a nearby couch. A duvet was crumpled on top of it. It appeared as though a lighter was held up to it, after which flames had fanned upwards.|||查尔斯·科利尔是消防局的一名分区官员。他检查了客厅里劳伦斯脚边被点燃的火堆的烧焦残余物。它是由一堆衣服、一件格子衬衫、一条牛仔裤和两只靴子制成的。看起来劳伦斯在遭受最初的袭击后，袭击者把他的身体拖到了这个地方。下面的地毯上有一个半圆形的烧焦痕迹。科利尔警官可以看出这是蓄意点燃的，但找不到任何助燃剂的痕迹。第二处火灾也是从附近的沙发蔓延开来的。一条羽绒被揉成一团堆在上面。看起来像是有人拿打火机凑近它，随后火焰向上窜起。
This fire also looked deliberate. The arsonist had likely hoped that either fire would take hold and rapidly destroy their house, consuming the victim and any evidence linking them to the crime. There was no sign of forced entry into the house. John Haggett claimed that the front door was open when he entered the living room and found Lawrence. He didn't see anyone fleeing. Police suspected that the culprit either knocked on the front door or was already inside before launching their attack. A search of the property failed to uncover the weapon used to inflict Lawrence's injuries. Near 30 miles south-east of Valarbet, 36-year-old Larry Haggett arrived at Edinburgh's Western General Hospital.
This fire also looked deliberate. The arsonist had likely hoped that either fire would take hold and rapidly destroy their house, consuming the victim and any evidence linking them to the crime. There was no sign of forced entry into the house. John Haggett claimed that the front door was open when he entered the living room and found Lawrence. He didn't see anyone fleeing. Police suspected that the culprit either knocked on the front door or was already inside before launching their attack. A search of the property failed to uncover the weapon used to inflict Lawrence's injuries. Near 30 miles south-east of Valarbet, 36-year-old Larry Haggett arrived at Edinburgh's Western General Hospital.|||这场火灾看起来也是蓄意制造的。纵火犯很可能是希望其中一场大火能够燃起并迅速烧毁他们的房子，吞噬受害者以及任何与犯罪有关的证据。房子没有被强行闯入的迹象。约翰·哈盖特声称，当他进入客厅并发现劳伦斯时，前门是开着的。他没有看到任何人逃跑。警察怀疑罪犯要么敲了前门，要么在发动袭击之前就已经在屋内了。对该房产的搜查未能找到造成劳伦斯受伤的武器。在瓦拉伯特东南约30英里处，36岁的拉里·哈盖特抵达了爱丁堡西部总医院。
He'd received a call notifying him that his second-older son had been in an accident. He arrived quickly, but no one was able to give him a clear explanation. All he was told was that Lawrence sustained blunt-force trauma to the head. It had resulted in brain damage and a massive skull fracture that extended to the right side of his face. Lawrence underwent emergency surgery and was placed on life support. Larry joined Janet at their son's side, where the pair kept a vigil into the following morning of Sunday, March 17. The brutal attack made local news, though Lawrence's identity was withheld as some of his relatives had yet to be informed. An article in the Sunday Mail newspaper did mention that a rising Celtic star was fighting for his life.
He'd received a call notifying him that his second-older son had been in an accident. He arrived quickly, but no one was able to give him a clear explanation. All he was told was that Lawrence sustained blunt-force trauma to the head. It had resulted in brain damage and a massive skull fracture that extended to the right side of his face. Lawrence underwent emergency surgery and was placed on life support. Larry joined Janet at their son's side, where the pair kept a vigil into the following morning of Sunday, March 17. The brutal attack made local news, though Lawrence's identity was withheld as some of his relatives had yet to be informed. An article in the Sunday Mail newspaper did mention that a rising Celtic star was fighting for his life.|||他接到一个电话，通知他他的二儿子出了事故。他很快赶到，但没有人能给他一个明确的解释。他只被告知劳伦斯头部遭受了钝器伤。这导致了脑损伤和一个延伸到他脸右侧的大面积颅骨骨折。劳伦斯接受了紧急手术，并被依靠生命维持系统维持生命。拉里来到儿子身边与珍妮特会合，两人守夜到3月17日星期天清晨。这起残忍的袭击登上了当地新闻，不过劳伦斯的身份被保密，因为他的一些亲戚尚未得到通知。《星期日邮报》上的一篇文章确实提到了一位冉冉升起的凯尔特人球星正在为生命而战。
Celtic youth team boss Willie McStay told the paper, Let's just hope to God he pulls through. Later that day, it was determined that Lawrence would not recover from his injuries. A priest arrived at the hospital and gave the 15-year-old his last rights. Lawrence's ventilator was turned off and he quietly passed away. His death rocked Scotland's footballing community. Celtic manager Tommy Burns told the local press that the club was shocked. He expressed his condolences to the Haggard family.
Celtic youth team boss Willie McStay told the paper, Let's just hope to God he pulls through. Later that day, it was determined that Lawrence would not recover from his injuries. A priest arrived at the hospital and gave the 15-year-old his last rights. Lawrence's ventilator was turned off and he quietly passed away. His death rocked Scotland's footballing community. Celtic manager Tommy Burns told the local press that the club was shocked. He expressed his condolences to the Haggard family.|||凯尔特人青年队老板威利·麦克斯特伊对该报说：“让我们祈求上帝他能挺过来。”那天晚些时候，人们确定劳伦斯将无法从伤病中恢复过来。一名牧师赶到医院，为这名15岁的少年做了临终祈祷。劳伦斯的呼吸机被拔掉，他静静地离世了。他的死震动了苏格兰足球界。凯尔特人主教练汤米·伯恩斯对当地媒体表示，俱乐部感到震惊。他对哈加德一家表示哀悼。
The coach of Scotland's international under-15 squad echoed these sentiments, telling reporters, Lawrence had great pace and vision. He was just at the beginning of what would certainly have been a top-class career. Because Lawrence had undergone significant surgery, it was impossible to determine exactly how many times he was struck to the head. But it was clear that the attack had been extremely violent and carried out with a heavy object. It had caused skull fractures similar to those sustained by road accident victims who've been thrown through the windscreen of a car. His legs and his feet were severely burnt, exposing the tissue underneath. The soles of both feet were charred black.
The coach of Scotland's international under-15 squad echoed these sentiments, telling reporters, Lawrence had great pace and vision. He was just at the beginning of what would certainly have been a top-class career. Because Lawrence had undergone significant surgery, it was impossible to determine exactly how many times he was struck to the head. But it was clear that the attack had been extremely violent and carried out with a heavy object. It had caused skull fractures similar to those sustained by road accident victims who've been thrown through the windscreen of a car. His legs and his feet were severely burnt, exposing the tissue underneath. The soles of both feet were charred black.|||苏格兰国际U15代表队的教练也表达了同样的看法，他告诉记者：“劳伦斯拥有出色的速度和视野。他才刚刚开始一段注定是顶级水平的职业生涯。”由于劳伦斯接受了重大手术，因此无法确定他的头部究竟被击打过多少次。但很明显，这次袭击极其暴力，是用重物实施的。它造成的颅骨骨折类似于车祸受害者被甩出挡风玻璃时受到的骨折。他的双腿和双脚严重烧伤，露出了下面的组织。两只脚底都被烧焦发黑。
There were no defensive injuries or wounds consistent with the fight. It appeared as though Lawrence was taken by surprise, either by an individual or multiple offenders. The teen had also been mutilated. The number's 110 had been gouged into one of Lawrence's shoulders, most likely with a key. Both of his palms had the same number written on them in ink. Police resources at the time of Lawrence's murder were limited, as it occurred just days after an unrelated national tragedy. At 9.30 am on Wednesday, March 13, a 43-year-old man entered Dunblane Primary School near the city of Sterling. Armed with four legally-owned handguns, he opened fire on a class of 28 students.
There were no defensive injuries or wounds consistent with the fight. It appeared as though Lawrence was taken by surprise, either by an individual or multiple offenders. The teen had also been mutilated. The number's 110 had been gouged into one of Lawrence's shoulders, most likely with a key. Both of his palms had the same number written on them in ink. Police resources at the time of Lawrence's murder were limited, as it occurred just days after an unrelated national tragedy. At 9.30 am on Wednesday, March 13, a 43-year-old man entered Dunblane Primary School near the city of Sterling. Armed with four legally-owned handguns, he opened fire on a class of 28 students.|||没有防卫伤或与搏斗相符的伤口。看起来劳伦斯是被一个人或多名罪犯偷袭了。这名青少年还遭到了肢解。数字“110”被刻在劳伦斯的一个肩膀上，很可能是用钥匙刻的。他的两个手掌上都用墨水写着同样的数字。在劳伦斯被谋杀时，警方的资源是有限的，因为这发生在几天前一起不相关的国家悲剧之后。3月13日星期三上午9点30分，一名43岁男子进入了斯特灵市附近的邓布兰小学。他手持四支合法拥有的手枪，向一个有28名学生的班级开枪。
16 children aged between 5 and 6 years old were killed, as was their 45-year-old teacher. A further 15 children were injured. The gunman then took his own life. The attack would come to be known as the Dunblane Massacre and remains the deadliest mass shooting in British history. March of Scotland's police resources were channeled into investigating the major incident. Lawrence Haggert's case was relegated to Central Scotland Police. They had jurisdiction over the council areas of Falkirk, Sterling and Clackmanonshire. The high-profile case was, in hindsight, a lot for the small force to handle. The Haggert homicide investigation was led by Detective Superintendent Jim Winning and his second-in-command Detective Inspector John Bunyan.
16 children aged between 5 and 6 years old were killed, as was their 45-year-old teacher. A further 15 children were injured. The gunman then took his own life. The attack would come to be known as the Dunblane Massacre and remains the deadliest mass shooting in British history. March of Scotland's police resources were channeled into investigating the major incident. Lawrence Haggert's case was relegated to Central Scotland Police. They had jurisdiction over the council areas of Falkirk, Sterling and Clackmanonshire. The high-profile case was, in hindsight, a lot for the small force to handle. The Haggert homicide investigation was led by Detective Superintendent Jim Winning and his second-in-command Detective Inspector John Bunyan.|||16名年龄在5到6岁之间的儿童遇害，他们45岁的老师也不幸身亡。另有15名儿童受伤。随后，枪手自杀身亡。这次袭击后来被称为“邓布兰惨案”，至今仍是英国历史上最致命的大规模枪击事件。苏格兰的警察资源大部分都被调去调查这一重大事件。劳伦斯·哈加德的案件被交给了苏格兰中部警方。他们对福尔柯克、斯特灵和克拉克曼南郡的议会区拥有管辖权。事后看来，这个备受瞩目的案件对于这支规模不大的警力来说实在难以应付。哈加德谋杀案的调查由侦探警司吉姆·威宁和他的副手、侦探督察约翰·班扬领导。
Lawrence's final hours were pieced together based on the statements of those he interacted with during that time. Hours before he was attacked, Lawrence had gone out with friends to an underage nightclub called Ziggy's in the nearby town of Denney. A neighbour observed him leaving home. He was dressed in cream-coloured jeans, a white t-shirt, a dark blue and white striped top, a cream bomber jacket and brown boots. He met up with friends and the group went to Ziggy's. Lawrence wasn't the type to stay out later than allowed, so he left the club just before 10. Together with a friend, he caught a taxi outside the Lion and Dragon pub, which was located in a narrow alleyway called Church Walk. When they reached the small village of Bonnie Bridge, Lawrence's friend exited the vehicle. Lawrence continued on in the taxi alone for another three miles.
Lawrence's final hours were pieced together based on the statements of those he interacted with during that time. Hours before he was attacked, Lawrence had gone out with friends to an underage nightclub called Ziggy's in the nearby town of Denney. A neighbour observed him leaving home. He was dressed in cream-coloured jeans, a white t-shirt, a dark blue and white striped top, a cream bomber jacket and brown boots. He met up with friends and the group went to Ziggy's. Lawrence wasn't the type to stay out later than allowed, so he left the club just before 10. Together with a friend, he caught a taxi outside the Lion and Dragon pub, which was located in a narrow alleyway called Church Walk. When they reached the small village of Bonnie Bridge, Lawrence's friend exited the vehicle. Lawrence continued on in the taxi alone for another three miles.|||劳伦斯的最后几个小时是根据他在那段时间接触过的人的陈述拼凑出来的。在遭到袭击几小时前，劳伦斯和朋友们去了附近丹尼镇一家名为齐格斯的未成年人夜总会。一位邻居看到他离开家。他穿着米色牛仔裤、白色T恤、深蓝白相间的上衣、米色飞行员夹克和棕色靴子。他与朋友会合，一行人去了齐格斯。劳伦斯不是那种会晚归的人，所以他在快到10点时离开了夜总会。他和朋友一起在“狮子与龙”酒吧外面叫了一辆出租车，酒吧位于一条名为“教堂步道”的狭窄小巷里。当他们到达小村庄邦尼布里奇时，劳伦斯的朋友下了车。劳伦斯独自乘出租车又行驶了三英里。
He got out at the village of Camelon, south of La Berte. A witness spotted him walking towards the Falkirk Sheriff Court building. He walked the remaining two miles home. John was alone in the living room watching television when Lawrence walked through the door at 10.30pm. Dennis was still out, but arrived home a short while later. Lawrence spoke briefly to his brothers, then settled on the sofa and read a newspaper. John and Dennis went to their respective beds. After a little while, Dennis got up to fetch some crisps from the kitchen.
He got out at the village of Camelon, south of La Berte. A witness spotted him walking towards the Falkirk Sheriff Court building. He walked the remaining two miles home. John was alone in the living room watching television when Lawrence walked through the door at 10.30pm. Dennis was still out, but arrived home a short while later. Lawrence spoke briefly to his brothers, then settled on the sofa and read a newspaper. John and Dennis went to their respective beds. After a little while, Dennis got up to fetch some crisps from the kitchen.|||他在拉伯特以南的卡梅伦村下了车。一位目击者看到他朝着福尔柯克治安法院大楼走去。他步行走完了剩下的两英里回家。晚上10点30分劳伦斯进门时，约翰独自一人在客厅看电视。丹尼斯还没回来，但不久后也到家了。劳伦斯与弟弟们短暂交谈了几句，然后坐在沙发上读报纸。约翰和丹尼斯各自回了卧室。过了一会儿，丹尼斯起身去厨房拿了些薯片。
From upstairs, John heard his two younger brothers talking into the sound of a kitchen cupboard closing. He then fell asleep. Dennis went back to bed. Shortly afterwards, he thought he heard Lawrence enter their bedroom, pick up his duvet, then go downstairs. Investigators were unable to establish a clear motive. They briefly considered the possibility that it was sexual, as Lawrence was found in nothing else but his underwear. Most of the clothing he had worn to the club was used to start the fire at his feet. One convicted sex offender was initially of interest to police, but was quickly ruled out after providing an alibi.
From upstairs, John heard his two younger brothers talking into the sound of a kitchen cupboard closing. He then fell asleep. Dennis went back to bed. Shortly afterwards, he thought he heard Lawrence enter their bedroom, pick up his duvet, then go downstairs. Investigators were unable to establish a clear motive. They briefly considered the possibility that it was sexual, as Lawrence was found in nothing else but his underwear. Most of the clothing he had worn to the club was used to start the fire at his feet. One convicted sex offender was initially of interest to police, but was quickly ruled out after providing an alibi.|||从楼上，约翰听到两个弟弟说话的声音，伴随着厨房橱柜关上的声音。随后他睡着了。丹尼斯回到了床上。不久之后，他以为自己听到劳伦斯进了他们的卧室，拿起了他的羽绒被，然后下楼了。调查人员无法确定明确的动机。他们曾短暂考虑过这可能是性侵犯罪的可能，因为人们发现劳伦斯只穿着内衣。他在夜总会穿的大部分衣服都被用来点燃他脚边的火。一名被定罪的性犯罪者最初引起了警方的兴趣，但在提供了不在场证明后很快被排除。
Rumours spread that the murder was motivated by Lawrence's affiliation with Celtic Football Club. The club had a historic association with Irish immigrants who'd moved to Glasgow and Scots of Irish descent. This meant it also had strong ties to the Catholic Church, of which Lawrence was a member. Some speculated that the attack was the result of anti-Catholic prejudice. Lawrence's mother Janet was too distraught by her son's murder to speak about the matter publicly, so his father Larry took on the role of family spokesperson. Larry expressed his doubt that his son had been killed due to anti-Catholic prejudice. On Tuesday, March 19, police officially dismissed this theory.
Rumours spread that the murder was motivated by Lawrence's affiliation with Celtic Football Club. The club had a historic association with Irish immigrants who'd moved to Glasgow and Scots of Irish descent. This meant it also had strong ties to the Catholic Church, of which Lawrence was a member. Some speculated that the attack was the result of anti-Catholic prejudice. Lawrence's mother Janet was too distraught by her son's murder to speak about the matter publicly, so his father Larry took on the role of family spokesperson. Larry expressed his doubt that his son had been killed due to anti-Catholic prejudice. On Tuesday, March 19, police officially dismissed this theory.|||有传言称，这起谋杀案的动机与劳伦斯效力于凯尔特人足球俱乐部有关。该俱乐部与移居格拉斯哥的爱尔兰移民以及具有爱尔兰血统的苏格兰人有着历史渊源。这意味着它也与天主教会有着紧密的联系，而劳伦斯正是天主教徒。有人推测，这次袭击是反天主教偏见的结果。劳伦斯的母亲珍妮特因儿子的谋杀案悲痛欲绝，无法公开谈论此事，因此他的父亲拉里承担起了家族发言人的角色。拉里对他的儿子是因为反天主教偏见而被杀的说法表示怀疑。3月19日星期二，警方正式驳斥了这一理论。
Superintendent Jim Winning said, There has been talk of a sectarian motive, but let me say that there is nothing so far in this inquiry to suggest that. We have no suspects at the moment, and I would say that this is a seemingly motive-less attack. Police were quick to take possession of the Haggart family home. Janet Haggart and her sons were unable to return to the house while the initial investigation was underway. The restrictions meant little to Janet, who avoided the property permanently following Lawrence's attack. On Friday, March 22, Detective Sergeant Robert Beveridge attended the house to collect clothing for the Haggart family. He'd also been told of a potential issue with the property's electricity and needed to check whether a power cord was needed.
Superintendent Jim Winning said, There has been talk of a sectarian motive, but let me say that there is nothing so far in this inquiry to suggest that. We have no suspects at the moment, and I would say that this is a seemingly motive-less attack. Police were quick to take possession of the Haggart family home. Janet Haggart and her sons were unable to return to the house while the initial investigation was underway. The restrictions meant little to Janet, who avoided the property permanently following Lawrence's attack. On Friday, March 22, Detective Sergeant Robert Beveridge attended the house to collect clothing for the Haggart family. He'd also been told of a potential issue with the property's electricity and needed to check whether a power cord was needed.|||警司吉姆·威宁说：“一直有关于宗派动机的传言，但我要说的是，到目前为止，调查中没有任何迹象表明这一点。我们目前没有嫌疑人，我想说这是一起看似毫无动机的袭击。”警方迅速接管了哈加德一家的住所。在初步调查进行期间，珍妮特·哈加德和她的儿子们无法返回家中。这些限制对珍妮特来说算不了什么，她在劳伦斯遭受袭击后就永久地避开了这处房产。3月22日星期五，侦探警长罗伯特·贝弗里奇来到这栋房子，为哈加德一家收集衣物。他还被告知该房产的电力可能存在问题，需要检查是否需要电源线。
While Detective Beveridge was in the kitchen, he caught a glimpse of something out of the corner of his eye. Flying along the side of the kitchen table was a hammer. Detective Beveridge pulled on a latex glove. He then picked up the tool and noticed what appeared to be a human hair stuck to it. The detective confiscated the item as evidence. Lawrence's funeral was held on Saturday, April 20. Approximately 500 mourners packed into the St. Alexander Roman Catholic Church in Stirling to farewell the young soccer star. The Celtic Football Club's entire first squad attended, dressed in the team's green and black tracksuits.
While Detective Beveridge was in the kitchen, he caught a glimpse of something out of the corner of his eye. Flying along the side of the kitchen table was a hammer. Detective Beveridge pulled on a latex glove. He then picked up the tool and noticed what appeared to be a human hair stuck to it. The detective confiscated the item as evidence. Lawrence's funeral was held on Saturday, April 20. Approximately 500 mourners packed into the St. Alexander Roman Catholic Church in Stirling to farewell the young soccer star. The Celtic Football Club's entire first squad attended, dressed in the team's green and black tracksuits.|||当贝弗里奇侦探在厨房时，他用眼角余光瞥见了一件东西。一把锤子正沿着厨房桌子的边缘飞过。贝弗里奇侦探戴上了一副乳胶手套。然后他捡起这件工具，注意到上面似乎粘着一根人发。侦探将这件物品作为证据没收了。劳伦斯的葬礼于4月20日星期六举行。大约500名哀悼者挤满了斯特灵的圣亚历山大罗马天主教堂，为这位年轻的足球明星送行。凯尔特人足球俱乐部的整个一线队都出席了，他们穿着球队的绿黑相间运动服。
They were joined by the club's youth teams and top-ranking officials. The officiating priest addressed Lawrence's unknown killer or killers, stating, If you can live with yourselves, keep silent. But if you have any compassion, come forward. Lawrence was late to rest at the hills of the Dunnipay Cemetery in Fallkirk, just five minutes from his father's home. Larry visited his son's grave daily to deliver fresh flowers and clean the headstone. A £1,000 reward for information leading to the identification of Lawrence's killer went unclaimed. The local community feared the violent killer was hiding amongst them and lived in constant anxiety, worried they'd strike again at any moment. In contrast, investigators were growing increasingly convinced that the perpetrator was closer to home.
They were joined by the club's youth teams and top-ranking officials. The officiating priest addressed Lawrence's unknown killer or killers, stating, If you can live with yourselves, keep silent. But if you have any compassion, come forward. Lawrence was late to rest at the hills of the Dunnipay Cemetery in Fallkirk, just five minutes from his father's home. Larry visited his son's grave daily to deliver fresh flowers and clean the headstone. A £1,000 reward for information leading to the identification of Lawrence's killer went unclaimed. The local community feared the violent killer was hiding amongst them and lived in constant anxiety, worried they'd strike again at any moment. In contrast, investigators were growing increasingly convinced that the perpetrator was closer to home.|||俱乐部青年队和高级官员也加入了他们的行列。主持葬礼的牧师向劳伦斯那未知的凶手或凶手喊话，称：“如果你们能问心无愧地活下去，那就保持沉默。但如果你们还有一丝同情心，就站出来吧。”劳伦斯最终长眠于福尔柯克的邓尼佩伊公墓山丘上，距离他父亲的家只有五分钟路程。拉里每天都去儿子的墓前献上鲜花，清理墓碑。悬赏1000英镑以获取能确定劳伦斯凶手身份的信息的赏金一直无人认领。当地社区害怕这个暴力凶手就藏在他们中间，生活在持续的焦虑中，担心他们随时会再次袭击。相比之下，调查人员越来越确信，肇事者就离他们更近。
They were primarily struck by the fact that there was no sign of forced entry in the Haggett House. Dennis Haggett was only 12 years old, but he was big for his age and physically strong. Despite being the youngest of the three Haggett boys, he appeared capable of overpowering both his brothers in a fight. From the outset of their investigation, Central Scotland police eyed Dennis with suspicion. They believed he had been jealous of Lawrence's success on the football field, and these feelings came to a head on Friday, March 15. It was theorised that Dennis confronted Lawrence that night, before lashing out in a fit of deadly rage. Detective Superintendent Jim Winning and Detective Inspector John Bunyan questioned Dennis. He maintained that he was proud of his older brother's football talents and wasn't at all envious.
They were primarily struck by the fact that there was no sign of forced entry in the Haggett House. Dennis Haggett was only 12 years old, but he was big for his age and physically strong. Despite being the youngest of the three Haggett boys, he appeared capable of overpowering both his brothers in a fight. From the outset of their investigation, Central Scotland police eyed Dennis with suspicion. They believed he had been jealous of Lawrence's success on the football field, and these feelings came to a head on Friday, March 15. It was theorised that Dennis confronted Lawrence that night, before lashing out in a fit of deadly rage. Detective Superintendent Jim Winning and Detective Inspector John Bunyan questioned Dennis. He maintained that he was proud of his older brother's football talents and wasn't at all envious.|||让他们深感震惊的是，哈盖特家中没有被强行闯入的迹象。丹尼斯·哈盖特只有12岁，但他个子很高，身体健壮。尽管他是哈盖特家三个男孩中最小的一个，但在打斗中他似乎有能力制服他的两个兄弟。从调查一开始，苏格兰中部警方就对丹尼斯投去了怀疑的目光。他们认为他一直嫉妒劳伦斯在足球场上的成功，这种情绪在3月15日星期五达到了顶点。据推论，丹尼斯当晚与劳伦斯对质，随后在一次致命的愤怒中大打出手。侦探警司吉姆·威宁和侦探督察约翰·班扬审讯了丹尼斯。他坚称自己为哥哥的足球才华感到骄傲，一点也不嫉妒。
They also questioned the eldest Haggett son, 17-year-old John. He denied that his two younger brothers had argued the evening before the attack. Yet, in another interview days later, John mentioned something he hadn't before. After finding Lawrence's burning body in the living room, he rushed upstairs to alert Dennis. Dennis was usually a deep sleeper who took a while to rouse. That night, Dennis woke up immediately. Investigators continued to press both John and Dennis. Then, two weeks after the murder, John revealed another unknown detail to police.
They also questioned the eldest Haggett son, 17-year-old John. He denied that his two younger brothers had argued the evening before the attack. Yet, in another interview days later, John mentioned something he hadn't before. After finding Lawrence's burning body in the living room, he rushed upstairs to alert Dennis. Dennis was usually a deep sleeper who took a while to rouse. That night, Dennis woke up immediately. Investigators continued to press both John and Dennis. Then, two weeks after the murder, John revealed another unknown detail to police.|||他们还讯问了哈盖特家的长子、17岁的约翰。他否认他的两个弟弟在袭击发生前一天晚上发生过争吵。然而，在几天后的另一次采访中，约翰提到了一件他以前没有说过的事。在客厅里发现劳伦斯燃烧的身体后，他冲上楼去叫醒丹尼斯。丹尼斯通常是个睡得很死的人，需要花点时间才能被叫醒。那天晚上，丹尼斯立刻就醒了。调查人员继续向约翰和丹尼斯施压。然后，在谋杀案发生两周后，约翰向警方透露了另一个鲜为人知的细节。
He admitted that Dennis and Lawrence had a disagreement shortly before the attack. He recalled Lawrence arriving home by his curfew that night, but Dennis had stayed out later than he was supposed to. When Dennis walked through the door after 10.30, John was upset. He shouted and accused Dennis of taking the mickey. Lawrence sided with John and agreed that Dennis should go to bed. This angered Dennis. He told them to fuck off and retreated to the bedroom he and Lawrence shared. Lawrence went into the bedroom not long after.
He admitted that Dennis and Lawrence had a disagreement shortly before the attack. He recalled Lawrence arriving home by his curfew that night, but Dennis had stayed out later than he was supposed to. When Dennis walked through the door after 10.30, John was upset. He shouted and accused Dennis of taking the mickey. Lawrence sided with John and agreed that Dennis should go to bed. This angered Dennis. He told them to fuck off and retreated to the bedroom he and Lawrence shared. Lawrence went into the bedroom not long after.|||他承认，丹尼斯和劳伦斯在袭击发生前不久曾发生过分歧. 他回忆说，劳伦斯那天晚上在宵禁前到家了，但丹尼斯在外面呆的时间比规定得要晚。当丹尼斯在10点半以后走进家门时，约翰很不高兴。他大喊大叫，指责丹尼斯在开玩笑。劳伦斯站在约翰这边，同意丹尼斯应该上床睡觉。这惹怒了丹尼斯。他叫他们滚蛋，然后退回到他和劳伦斯共用的卧室。不久之后，劳伦斯也进了卧室。
John overheard Dennis tell Lawrence to fuck off a second time. The conflict likely prompted Lawrence to sleep on the couch. He collected the duvet from his bed and headed back downstairs to the living room. A short while later, John overheard Dennis go down to the kitchen to get a snack. He heard Lawrence rebuke him again, stating, You are supposed to be in your bed. From the police's perspective, John's admissions proved they were right to suspect Dennis. There had clearly been some animosity between him and Lawrence on the night of the attack.
John overheard Dennis tell Lawrence to fuck off a second time. The conflict likely prompted Lawrence to sleep on the couch. He collected the duvet from his bed and headed back downstairs to the living room. A short while later, John overheard Dennis go down to the kitchen to get a snack. He heard Lawrence rebuke him again, stating, You are supposed to be in your bed. From the police's perspective, John's admissions proved they were right to suspect Dennis. There had clearly been some animosity between him and Lawrence on the night of the attack.|||约翰无意中听到丹尼斯第二次叫劳伦斯滚蛋。这场冲突很可能促使劳伦斯睡在沙发上。他从床上收起羽绒被，回到楼下的客厅。过了一会儿，约翰无意中听到丹尼斯下楼去厨房拿零食。他听到劳伦斯再次训斥他，说道：“你应该在床上睡觉。”从警察的角度来看，约翰的供述证明他们怀疑丹尼斯是正确的。在袭击发生的当晚，他与劳伦斯之间显然存在某种敌意。
Over the following months, both John and Dennis were interviewed several times in order to get to the truth of the matter. On one occasion, Dennis was held for six hours without arrest under the terms of the Criminal Justice Act. The interview was recorded on tape, but he didn't implicate himself in the crime and maintained his innocence. About two months after the murder, John Haggart shared another piece of information with investigators. The police submitted a report to the country's Crown Office in which they said there was circumstantial evidence tying Dennis Haggart to Lawrence's murder. It also suggested that John might have also been involved. Investigators told Larry Haggart that they had enough evidence to at least prove Dennis's guilt. They asked him to speak with his son and get him to confess, but Larry refused.
Over the following months, both John and Dennis were interviewed several times in order to get to the truth of the matter. On one occasion, Dennis was held for six hours without arrest under the terms of the Criminal Justice Act. The interview was recorded on tape, but he didn't implicate himself in the crime and maintained his innocence. About two months after the murder, John Haggart shared another piece of information with investigators. The police submitted a report to the country's Crown Office in which they said there was circumstantial evidence tying Dennis Haggart to Lawrence's murder. It also suggested that John might have also been involved. Investigators told Larry Haggart that they had enough evidence to at least prove Dennis's guilt. They asked him to speak with his son and get him to confess, but Larry refused.|||在接下来的几个月里，约翰和丹尼斯都被讯问了好几次，以查明事情的真相。有一次，根据《刑事司法法》的条款，丹尼斯在未被逮捕的情况下被拘留了六个小时。采访被录音了，但他没有将自己牵连到罪行中，并坚称自己是无辜的。谋杀案发生大约两个月后，约翰·哈加德向调查人员分享了另一条信息。警方提交了一份报告给国家的皇家检察署，其中他们表示有间接证据将丹尼斯·哈加德与劳伦斯的谋杀案联系起来。它还暗示约翰也可能参与其中。调查人员告诉拉里·哈加德，他们有足够的证据来至少证明丹尼斯的罪行。他们要求他与儿子谈谈并让他坦白，但拉里拒绝了。
The suspicion around Dennis and John Haggart remained throughout March of 1996. The public were not informed that the brothers were being treated as suspects, but those within the Haggart family were well aware. Privately, Larry Haggart was furious. He hadn't heard from investigators since July and was left with the impression that they had abandoned the case in favor of blaming Lawrence's siblings. In an interview with The Sunday Mail in September that year, Larry revealed his plans to hire a private investigator to get to the truth of the matter. Quote, It is over two months since I heard from the police. While they didn't say the case was closed, they left me believing that their investigation is over.
The suspicion around Dennis and John Haggett remained throughout March of 1996. The public were not informed that the brothers were being treated as suspects, but those within the Haggart family were well aware. Privately, Larry Haggart was furious. He hadn't heard from investigators since July and was left with the impression that they had abandoned the case in favor of blaming Lawrence's siblings. In an interview with The Sunday Mail in September that year, Larry revealed his plans to hire a private investigator to get to the truth of the matter. Quote, It is over two months since I heard from the police. While they didn't say the case was closed, they left me believing that their investigation is over.|||围绕丹尼斯和约翰·哈盖特的怀疑在1996年3月一直存在。公众并未被告知这两个兄弟被视为嫌疑人，但哈加德家族内部的人都心知肚明。私下里，拉里·哈加德愤怒不已。自7月以来，他一直没有收到调查人员的消息，并留下了这样一种印象：他们已经放弃了这个案件，转而将责任归咎于劳伦斯的兄弟姐妹。在那年9月接受《星期日邮报》采访时，拉里透露了他聘请私人侦探来查明事情真相的计划。原话是：“距离我听到警察的消息已经过去两个多月了。虽然他们没有说案件已经结案，但他们让我相信他们的调查已经结束了。”
They may come down on me like a ton of bricks for going out alone, but I have a duty to my dead son to get some sort of conclusion. The Sunday Mail sought a rebuttal from the investigating officers. Second in command, Detective Inspector John Bunyan said that police required more information before an arrest could be made. He stated, Six months down the road, we need to know if anyone has been speaking about the case since the initial flurry of publicity. We know most of Lawrence's movements up to his death. We need to know what happened in the final moments. Several months passed with no further developments in the case.
They may come down on me like a ton of bricks for going out alone, but I have a duty to my dead son to get some sort of conclusion. The Sunday Mail sought a rebuttal from the investigating officers. Second in command, Detective Inspector John Bunyan said that police required more information before an arrest could be made. He stated, Six months down the road, we need to know if anyone has been speaking about the case since the initial flurry of publicity. We know most of Lawrence's movements up to his death. We need to know what happened in the final moments. Several months passed with no further developments in the case.|||他们可能会因为我独自行动而对我大发雷霆，但我有责任为我死去的儿子讨个说法。《星期日邮报》试图征求调查警官的反驳。二把手、侦探督察约翰·班扬表示，警方在能够实施逮捕之前需要更多信息。他表示：“六个月过去了，我们需要知道自最初的广泛宣传以来是否有人一直在谈论这个案件。我们知道劳伦斯死前的大部分行踪。我们需要知道最后时刻发生了什么。”几个月过去了，案件没有取得进一步进展。
Then, towards the end of 1996, it was announced that lead investigator, Detective Superintendent Jim Winning, was being replaced as the head of the criminal investigation division at Central Scotland Police. Consequently, he would no longer be in charge of the Lawrence Haggart murder investigation. He was replaced by Superintendent Joe Holden and his second in command, Detective Gordon Munro. As the one-year anniversary of Lawrence's murder drew near, the crime received renewed attention when it was featured on an episode of the UK television program Crime Watch. Larry Haggart was in favour of the move, as he hoped that the publicity might help jog someone's memory. Yet, no leads emerged, further highlighting the possibility that those responsible were not hiding out in the community, but were remaining tight-lipped in the Haggart home. In March 1997, a memorial mass was held at Lawrence's High School. In the lead-up, Larry Haggart spoke of his continued struggle with grief.
Then, towards the end of 1996, it was announced that lead investigator, Detective Superintendent Jim Winning, was being replaced as the head of the criminal investigation division at Central Scotland Police. Consequently, he would no longer be in charge of the Lawrence Haggart murder investigation. He was replaced by Superintendent Joe Holden and his second in command, Detective Gordon Munro. As the one-year anniversary of Lawrence's murder drew near, the crime received renewed attention when it was featured on an episode of the UK television program Crime Watch. Larry Haggart was in favour of the move, as he hoped that the publicity might help jog someone's memory. Yet, no leads emerged, further highlighting the possibility that those responsible were not hiding out in the community, but were remaining tight-lipped in the Haggart home. In March 1997, a memorial mass was held at Lawrence's High School. In the lead-up, Larry Haggart spoke of his continued struggle with grief.|||然后，在1996年底，有消息称，首席调查员、侦探警司吉姆·威宁将被替换，不再担任苏格兰中部警方刑事调查部门的负责人。因此，他将不再负责劳伦斯·哈加德谋杀案的调查。接替他的是警司乔·霍尔登和他的副手、侦探戈登·芒罗。随着劳伦斯遇害一周年纪念日的临近，这起犯罪在英国电视节目《罪案观察》的一集节目中播出后，再次受到关注。拉里·哈加德赞成这一举动，因为他希望宣传可能有助于唤起某人的记忆。然而，没有出现任何线索，这进一步凸显了这样一种可能性：肇事者并没有躲在社区里，而是在哈加德家中守口如瓶。1997年3月，劳伦斯的中学举行了一场追悼弥撒。在此之前，拉里·哈加德谈到了他与悲痛的持续抗争。
He called Lawrence his best friend and said he visited his late son's grave every day. Quote, People say it gets easier, but every day is as hard as the first. By 1997, the relationship between the Haggarts and the police was fraught. The family firmly believed in Dennis and John's innocence, while the police were certain of their guilt. By the time Superintendent Joe Holden and Detective Gordon Munro took a fresh look at the case, the investigation had reached an impasse. As far as the original case detectives were concerned, Dennis and John Haggart were concealing the truth of what happened on March 16, 1996. No other possible suspect had raised their suspicions as much as the Haggart boys.
He called Lawrence his best friend and said he visited his late son's grave every day. Quote, People say it gets easier, but every day is as hard as the first. By 1997, the relationship between the Haggarts and the police was fraught. The family firmly believed in Dennis and John's innocence, while the police were certain of their guilt. By the time Superintendent Joe Holden and Detective Gordon Munro took a fresh look at the case, the investigation had reached an impasse. As far as the original case detectives were concerned, Dennis and John Haggett were concealing the truth of what happened on March 16, 1996. No other possible suspect had raised their suspicions as much as the Haggart boys.|||他称劳伦斯为他的最好朋友，并说他每天都去探望已故儿子的坟墓。原话是：“人们说事情会变得容易些，但每一天都和第一天一样艰难。”到1997年，哈加德一家与警方的关系已经十分紧张。这家人坚信丹尼斯和约翰是无辜的，而警方则确信他们有罪。当乔·霍尔登警司和戈登·芒罗侦探重新审视这起案件时，调查已经陷入僵局。就最初的案件侦探而言，丹尼斯和约翰·哈盖特隐瞒了1996年3月16日发生的事情的真相。没有其他可能的嫌疑人像哈加德兄弟那样引起他们的怀疑。
The Haggarts said that they only ever heard from investigators when they came to collect Dennis or John for questioning. Detectives Holden and Munro understood that nothing was being gained by keeping the Haggarts at a distance. As such, they set about establishing a positive relationship with the family. After months of being kept in the dark, the Haggarts were now speaking regularly with police and receiving weekly updates on the case. The initial investigators had presented a convincing set of circumstances to support the theory that the Haggart brothers were involved in Lawrence's death, especially Dennis. Even though Detectives Holden and Munro were willing to explore other scenarios, they still had to rule out the possibility that someone in the household had committed the crime. Renowned English criminal psychologist Adrian West was brought in to interview Dennis and John Haggart. After speaking with the pair, West concluded that there was no way either had killed Lawrence.
The Haggarts said that they only ever heard from investigators when they came to collect Dennis or John for questioning. Detectives Holden and Munro understood that nothing was being gained by keeping the Haggarts at a distance. As such, they set about establishing a positive relationship with the family. After months of being kept in the dark, the Haggarts were now speaking regularly with police and receiving weekly updates on the case. The initial investigators had presented a convincing set of circumstances to support the theory that the Haggart brothers were involved in Lawrence's death, especially Dennis. Even though Detectives Holden and Munro were willing to explore other scenarios, they still had to rule out the possibility that someone in the household had committed the crime. Renowned English criminal psychologist Adrian West was brought in to interview Dennis and John Haggett. After speaking with the pair, West concluded that there was no way either had killed Lawrence.|||哈加德一家表示，他们只有在调查人员来带走丹尼斯或约翰进行讯问时才会听到他们的消息。霍尔登和芒罗侦探明白，与哈加德一家保持距离没有任何好处。因此，他们着手与这个家庭建立积极的关系。在被蒙在鼓里几个月之后，哈加德一家现在定期与警方交谈，并每周收到案件的最新进展。最初的调查人员提出了一套令人信服的情况，以支持哈加德兄弟参与劳伦斯之死的理论，尤其是丹尼斯。尽管霍尔登和芒罗侦探愿意探索其他情况，但他们仍然必须排除家中某人犯下罪行的可能性。著名英国犯罪心理学家阿德里安·韦斯特被请来采访丹尼斯和约翰·哈盖特。在与两人交谈后，韦斯特得出结论，两人都不可能杀死劳伦斯。
Superintendent Holden felt vindicated by this finding. He'd been dubious about the brothers' involvement since first looking at the case. To his thinking, the crime was simply too bizarre and too brutal for either to have done it. He later told the Scotsman newspaper, We just had a gut feeling that the circumstances of the crime, the mutilation of Lawrence's shoulder, the motive that we felt was either sadistic or sexual, could not be laid at the feet of Dennis, who was 12 at the time, or John. No brother could have done what was done to Lawrence, then tortured him, before going upstairs to his bedroom to sleep. With Dennis and John Haggart ruled out, other suspects named in the original investigation were re-examined. One was a 31-year-old convicted sex offender named Brian Beatty.
Superintendent Holden felt vindicated by this finding. He'd been dubious about the brothers' involvement since first looking at the case. To his thinking, the crime was simply too bizarre and too brutal for either to have done it. He later told the Scotsman newspaper, We just had a gut feeling that the circumstances of the crime, the mutilation of Lawrence's shoulder, the motive that we felt was either sadistic or sexual, could not be laid at the feet of Dennis, who was 12 at the time, or John. No brother could have done what was done to Lawrence, then tortured him, before going upstairs to his bedroom to sleep. With Dennis and John Haggett ruled out, other suspects named in the original investigation were re-examined. One was a 31-year-old convicted sex offender named Brian Beatty.|||霍尔登警司对这一发现感到如释重负。自从第一次看这个案子以来，他对这两兄弟的涉案情况一直持怀疑态度。在他看来，这起罪行实在是太离奇、太残酷了，无论是谁都不可能做出这种事。他后来告诉《苏格兰人报》：“我们只是有一种直觉，犯罪的情况、劳伦斯肩膀的残缺、我们认为既虐待狂又带性质的动机，都不能归咎于当时12岁的丹尼斯或约翰。没有任何兄弟会对劳伦斯做出那样的事，然后折磨他，最后上楼回卧室睡觉。”随着丹尼斯和约翰·哈盖特的嫌疑被排除，最初调查中提到的其他嫌疑人被重新审视。其中一人是一名31岁、有性犯罪前科的男子，名叫布莱恩·比蒂。
Beatty was the youngest of four brothers raised in the village of Airth in the Falkirk Council area. As a child, he had attended a number of list D schools, a term for Scottish schools that were under the control of local social work departments. His parents eventually separated when his mother pursued a relationship with another man. She moved to the town of Redcar in England, where she got a job as a bus conductor. The teenaged Beatty followed his mother to Redcar, where he began catching the same buses that she worked on. Beatty observed the travelling habits of local pensioners, and would break into their properties when he knew they would be out. As well as stealing any valuables he found, he started fires in some of the residences. He was arrested in 1984 and charged with four counts of burglary and two counts of arson.
Beatty was the youngest of four brothers raised in the village of Airth in the Falkirk Council area. As a child, he had attended a number of list D schools, a term for Scottish schools that were under the control of local social work departments. His parents eventually separated when his mother pursued a relationship with another man. She moved to the town of Redcar in England, where she got a job as a bus conductor. The teenaged Beatty followed his mother to Redcar, where he began catching the same buses that she worked on. Beatty observed the travelling habits of local pensioners, and would break into their properties when he knew they would be out. As well as stealing any valuables he found, he started fires in some of the residences. He was arrested in 1984 and charged with four counts of burglary and two counts of arson.|||比蒂是在福尔柯克议会区的埃尔斯村长大的四个兄弟中最小的一个。小时候，他上过许多D类学校，这是苏格兰受当地社会工作部门控制的学校的统称。当他的母亲与另一个男人谈恋爱时，他的父母最终分居了。她搬到了英格兰的雷德卡镇，在那里找到了一份公交车售票员的工作。十几岁的比蒂跟着母亲去了雷德卡，并在那里开始搭乘母亲工作的同一路公交车。比蒂观察了当地退休人员的出行习惯，并在知道他们不在家时闯入他们的住所。除了偷走他发现的任何贵重物品外，他还在一些住所里纵火。他在1984年被捕，被控四项入室盗窃罪和两项纵火罪。
While on remand, Beatty set fire to his prison cell. He also attempted suicide by lighting himself on fire. Beatty pleaded guilty to all charges. He was labelled a fire risk and a danger to the public. The judge contemplated giving him a life sentence, but instead sentenced him to seven years. Beatty was released on parole four years later in 1988 and moved back to Scotland. By November of that year, he had started a new series of crimes. Beatty would study houses around his hometown of Erth. This time, he took note of where adolescent boys lived. His first target was a house in the town of Stenhouse Muir. Late one night, Beatty broke into the property and entered the bedroom of a 14-year-old boy.
While on remand, Beatty set fire to his prison cell. He also attempted suicide by lighting himself on fire. Beatty pleaded guilty to all charges. He was labelled a fire risk and a danger to the public. The judge contemplated giving him a life sentence, but instead sentenced him to seven years. Beatty was released on parole four years later in 1988 and moved back to Scotland. By November of that year, he had started a new series of crimes. Beatty would study houses around his hometown of Erth. This time, he took note of where adolescent boys lived. His first target was a house in the town of Stenhouse Muir. Late one night, Beatty broke into the property and entered the bedroom of a 14-year-old boy.|||在还押候审期间，比蒂点燃了自己的监狱牢房。他还试图通过自焚来。比蒂对所有指控均认罪。他被贴上了火灾隐患和对公众危险的标签。法官考虑判处他终身监禁，但最终判处他七年徒刑。四年后的1988年，比蒂获得假释出狱，并搬回了苏格兰。到当年11月，他开始了一系列新的犯罪活动。比蒂会研究他家乡埃尔斯周围的房屋。这一次，他注意到了青春期男孩居住的地方。他的第一个目标是斯滕豪斯缪尔镇的一栋房子。一天深夜，比蒂闯入该物业，进入了一个14岁男孩的卧室。
Beatty tried to sexually assault the teen but fled when his victim fought back. More than 18 months later, in August 1990, Beatty broke into a house in Falkirk under the cover of darkness and attacked a 17-year-old male. The victim woke to find Beatty pressing a pair of scissors against his stomach. He was ordered to turn over and lie face down. Beatty covered his head with a pillow and duvet while threatening to kill him if he looked at his face. He then sexually assaulted the boy before running from the scene. Three weeks later, a 21-year-old male was asleep in his family's home in Stenhouse Muir. He woke to find Beatty holding a knife to his stomach.
Beatty tried to sexually assault the teen but fled when his victim fought back. More than 18 months later, in August 1990, Beatty broke into a house in Falkirk under the cover of darkness and attacked a 17-year-old male. The victim woke to find Beatty pressing a pair of scissors against his stomach. He was ordered to turn over and lie face down. Beatty covered his head with a pillow and duvet while threatening to kill him if he looked at his face. He then sexually assaulted the boy before running from the scene. Three weeks later, a 21-year-old male was asleep in his family's home in Stenhouse Muir. He woke to find Beatty holding a knife to his stomach.|||比蒂试图性侵这名少年，但当受害者反抗时，他逃跑了。18个多月后的1990年8月，比蒂在夜色的掩护下闯入福尔柯克的一所房子，袭击了一名17岁男子。受害者醒来发现比蒂正把一把剪刀压在他的腹部。他被命令翻身并脸朝下躺着。比蒂用枕头和羽绒被蒙住他的头，并威胁说如果他看他的脸就杀了他。然后他性侵了男孩，随后逃离了现场。三周后，一名21岁男子在斯滕豪斯缪尔的家中睡觉。他醒来发现比蒂拿着一把刀抵着他的腹部。
Beatty's other hand was pressed against the victim's genitals. He threatened to slash the young man if he moved, but the victim pushed him off and chased him from the room. In October of 1990, Beatty targeted a house in Larbert, the town where Lawrence Haggett lived. He threatened an 18-year-old male resident with a screwdriver before sexually assaulting him. Within five days, Beatty struck again. He broke into a house belonging to a former Scottish football star and assaulted his 14-year-old son. Beatty was eventually arrested for his string of attacks, but was released on bail. Six days later, he assaulted a 21-year-old man at his home in Fallkirk.
Beatty's other hand was pressed against the victim's genitals. He threatened to slash the young man if he moved, but the victim pushed him off and chased him from the room. In October of 1990, Beatty targeted a house in Larbert, the town where Lawrence Haggett lived. He threatened an 18-year-old male resident with a screwdriver before sexually assaulting him. Within five days, Beatty struck again. He broke into a house belonging to a former Scottish football star and assaulted his 14-year-old son. Beatty was eventually arrested for his string of attacks, but was released on bail. Six days later, he assaulted a 21-year-old man at his home in Fallkirk.|||比蒂的另一只手按在受害者的生殖器上。他威胁说如果这个年轻人动一下就会划伤他，但受害者把他推开并把他赶出了房间。1990年10月，比蒂将目标锁定在拉伯特的一所房子里，劳伦斯·哈盖特就住在那个镇上。他用一把螺丝刀威胁一名18岁男居民，然后实施了性侵。五天之内，比蒂再次作案。他闯入了一名前苏格兰足球明星的房子，袭击了他14岁的儿子。比蒂最终因这一连串的袭击而被捕，但获保释。六天后，他在福尔柯克的家中袭击了一名21岁男子。
In February 1991, Beatty faced Edinburgh's High Court charged with multiple counts of assault. He was sentenced to just 18 months in prison. Within eight months, he had been granted parole. Three days after his release, Beatty was loitering on a residential street in Stenhouse Muir in the early hours of the morning. He silently entered a nearby house and made his way to the bedroom of the 16-year-old boy who lived there. The teen was fast asleep. Beatty covered the boy's head with a blanket and a t-shirt. He warned him that he had a knife before tying the boy's wrists with a shirt and a wire.
In February 1991, Beatty faced Edinburgh's High Court charged with multiple counts of assault. He was sentenced to just 18 months in prison. Within eight months, he had been granted parole. Three days after his release, Beatty was loitering on a residential street in Stenhouse Muir in the early hours of the morning. He silently entered a nearby house and made his way to the bedroom of the 16-year-old boy who lived there. The teen was fast asleep. Beatty covered the boy's head with a blanket and a t-shirt. He warned him that he had a knife before tying the boy's wrists with a shirt and a wire.|||1991年2月，比蒂因面临多项指控而出庭受审于爱丁堡高等法院。他被判处仅18个月监禁。在八个月内，他获得了假释。在他获释三天后的清晨，比蒂在斯滕豪斯缪尔的一条住宅街道上闲逛。他悄悄进入附近的一栋房子，径直走进住在那里的一名16岁男孩的卧室。这名少年正睡得正香。比蒂用一条毯子和一件T恤盖住男孩的头。他警告他自己有一把刀，然后用一件衬衫和一根铁丝捆住了男孩的手腕。
For the first time ever, Beatty ordered his victim out of their house. He was going to carry out the assault elsewhere at his own pace and under his full control. Yet, the boy managed to pull the covering from his head and saw his attack his face. Beatty fled, but was soon apprehended again. This time, he was sentenced to five years in prison. In September 1994, he was once again released early on parole. He lived in Edinburgh for several months, then returned to the Fallkirk area. Roy and Beatty was questioned by police the day after Lawrence Haggert was attacked.
For the first time ever, Beatty ordered his victim out of their house. He was going to carry out the assault elsewhere at his own pace and under his full control. Yet, the boy managed to pull the covering from his head and saw his attack his face. Beatty fled, but was soon apprehended again. This time, he was sentenced to five years in prison. In September 1994, he was once again released early on parole. He lived in Edinburgh for several months, then returned to the Fallkirk area. Roy and Beatty was questioned by police the day after Lawrence Haggert was attacked.|||比蒂有史以来第一次命令受害者离开他们的房子。他打算在其他地方按照自己的节奏并在自己的完全控制下进行袭击。然而，这个男孩设法把蒙在头上的遮盖物扯下来，看到了他的脸被袭击。比蒂逃跑了，但不久后再次被捕。这一次，他被判处五年监禁。1994年9月，他再次获得假释提前出狱。他在爱丁堡住了几个月，然后回到了福尔柯克地区。罗伊和比蒂在劳伦斯·哈加德遭到袭击的第二天受到了警方的审讯。
He provided an alibi, saying that he was at his brother's home until 9.30pm on March 15. He then drove to Edinburgh and parked in the grass market, a historic market area in the city's old town. He walked one and a half miles to a street called Royal Terrace, a known cruising area for gay men. Beatty said he arrived there by about 11pm and stayed in the area for around an hour and a half. During that time, he met a man and had oral sex with him. The men parted ways after about 15 minutes without sharing names or any other personal information. Beatty said he arrived home by 2am. When asked if he'd been near Lawrence Haggert's house, he replied,
He provided an alibi, saying that he was at his brother's home until 9.30pm on March 15. He then drove to Edinburgh and parked in the grass market, a historic market area in the city's old town. He walked one and a half miles to a street called Royal Terrace, a known cruising area for gay men. Beatty said he arrived there by about 11pm and stayed in the area for around an hour and a half. During that time, he met a man and had oral sex with him. The men parted ways after about 15 minutes without sharing names or any other personal information. Beatty said he arrived home by 2am. When asked if he'd been near Lawrence Haggert's house, he replied,|||他提供了不在场证明，称3月15日晚上9点半之前他一直待在哥哥家里。然后他开车去爱丁堡，把车停在草场市场，这是该市老城区的一个历史悠久的市场区。他步行了一英里半到达一条名为皇家露台的街道，这是一个众所周知的同性恋男性的寻欢区。比蒂说他大约在晚上11点到达那里，并在该地区停留了一个半小时左右。在此期间，他遇到了一个男人并与他发生了口交。大约15分钟后，两人分道扬镳，没有分享姓名或任何其他个人信息。比蒂说他在凌晨2点前回到家。当被问及他是否去过劳伦斯·哈加德的家附近时，他回答说：
I'm positive I wasn't in that area last night at all. Investigators at the time didn't believe the crime was sexually motivated. Beatty's alibi was accepted and he wasn't pursued any further as a suspect. The scorched carpet and couch from the crime scene had been discarded during the initial investigation. Neither item underwent a detailed forensic examination. This left investigators reexamining the case with little in the way of physical evidence. All they had was a series of photographs taken at the scene and a pubic hair recovered from Lawrence's underwear. Yet, the hair wasn't of any value. Testing confirmed it belonged to Lawrence.
我绝对确信昨晚我根本没去过那个地方。当时的调查人员不认为这起犯罪带有性动机。贝蒂的不在场证明被采纳了，他也没有被作为嫌疑人继续追查。案发现场烧焦的地毯和沙发在最初的调查中已被丢弃。这两件物品都没有经过详细的法医检验。这使得调查人员在重新审视该案时几乎没有什么物证。他们拥有的只有现场拍摄的一系列照片以及从劳伦斯的内裤中提取的一根阴毛。然而，这根毛发没有任何价值。经检测，它属于劳伦斯。
Investigators sought assistance from the National Crime Facility think tank at the Police Staff College in Bramshill, England. They determined that Beatty was the only known criminal whose profile fit the circumstances surrounding Lawrence Haggert's murder. He exclusively targeted adolescent boys and young men in their homes late at night. His attacks had occurred in or around the Fallkirk area. He had a history of committing arson to cover up his crimes. And in March of 1996, Beatty had lived in a caravan in Stenhouse, Muir, just a few miles from the Haggert home. By 1997, Brian Beatty still lived in Fallkirk. On Friday, August 22, police officers arrived at his home and placed him under arrest for willful fire-raising.
调查人员向位于英格兰布拉姆希尔警官学院的国家犯罪设施智库寻求协助。他们确定，贝蒂是唯一一个其侧写符合劳伦斯·哈格特谋杀案环境的已知罪犯。他专门在深夜潜入家中，将青春期男孩和年轻男子作为目标。他的袭击发生在法尔克拉克地区或其周边。他有通过纵火来掩盖罪行的历史。1996年3月，贝蒂住在斯滕豪斯缪尔的一个大篷车里，距离哈格特家只有几英里。到1997年，布赖恩·贝蒂仍然住在法尔克拉克。8月22日星期五，警察来到他家，以蓄意纵火罪将他逮捕。
The charge related to an incident that had occurred six months earlier in February and allowed police to hold Beatty for questioning for an extended period. The following day, a search of Beatty's residence was carried out. Draws in his bedroom contained two videotapes. Both were pornographic films that had been recorded from a German satellite channel. One was titled Redemption, the abduction series part three. It depicted fantasy scenarios in which young men were kidnapped from their homes, then used as sexual slaves. Some of the footage showed the men being whipped and tied up with strips of cloth. Beatty was questioned by detectives multiple times over the weekend.
这项指控与六个月前（即二月份）发生的一起事件有关，允许警方对贝蒂进行长时间的拘留审讯。第二天，警方对贝蒂的住所进行了搜查。他卧室的抽屉里有两盘录像带。两部都是从德国卫星频道录制的色情电影。其中一部名为《救赎：绑架系列第三部》。它描绘了一些幻想场景：年轻男子在家中被绑架，然后被当作性奴隶。一些画面显示这些人被鞭打并用布条捆绑。周末期间，侦探对贝蒂进行了多次讯问。
Lawrence Haggert's murder was discussed, though Beatty maintained he had nothing to do with it. Towards the end of one interview, however, he suddenly broke down in tears. He then began shaking, wailing and sobbing. Detective Gordon Munrow thought he looked like a child trapped in an adult's body. Beatty admitted that he had, quote, urges that disgusted him. The interview concluded there. During another interview in which Beatty was crying and distressed, detective Joe Holden asked him if he had killed Lawrence Haggert. Beatty nodded his head firmly about six times.
劳伦斯·哈格特的谋杀案受到了讨论，尽管贝蒂坚称这与他无关。然而，在其中一次讯问快结束时，他突然痛哭流涕。接着他开始颤抖、哀号和抽泣。侦探戈登·芒罗觉得他看起来像一个被困在成年人身体里的孩子。贝蒂承认他确实有让他感到恶心的“冲动”。审讯到此结束。在另一次审讯中，贝蒂哭泣且情绪痛苦，侦探乔·霍尔顿问他是否杀害了劳伦斯·哈格特。贝蒂坚定地点了大约六下头。
Holden inquired. Does that mean yes, Brian? Beatty replied that it did, then said he wanted to speak about it with his brother. The police fetched Beatty's brother, but when the pair spoke, Beatty reasserted his innocence. After this incident, Beatty reportedly told police he would confess on the condition that he wasn't recorded. Interviewing officers agreed and instead took detailed notes in a police notebook as he spoke. According to Detective Munrow, Beatty explained that he was outside at the Haggert family home on the night of March 16, 1996. Some neighbors across the road were having a party and a taxi arrived to either pick up or drop off a guest.
霍尔顿追问。布赖恩，这代表是吗？贝蒂回答说是的，然后说他想和他的哥哥谈谈这件事。警察找来了贝蒂的哥哥，但当两人交谈时，贝蒂重申了自己的清白。据报道，在此次事件之后，贝蒂告诉警方，他愿意在不被录音的条件下招供。讯问警官同意了，并在他说话时详细记在了警察的笔记本上。据芒罗侦探称，贝蒂解释说，他在1996年3月16日晚上的确在哈格特家族的房子外面。马路对面的一些邻居在开派对，一辆出租车到来接送客人。
Beatty approached the Haggert house and entered via the front door, which was apparently unlocked. He walked towards the living room door, which was shut. Beatty peered through its glass panes and saw Lawrence lying on the couch with a duvet or blanket pulled over him. Beatty opened the door and entered the room. Upon seeing the stranger, Lawrence got up and spoke. Beatty couldn't recall what he said. Beatty then hit Lawrence. He told investigators, quote, I can remember his face. I will never forget it. He fell back on the couch and I hit him again.
贝蒂走近哈格特家，从显然没锁的前门走了进去。他走向客厅紧闭的门。贝蒂透过玻璃窗向里看，看到劳伦斯躺在沙发上，身上盖着羽绒被或毯子。贝蒂推开门走进了房间。看到陌生人，劳伦斯站起来说了话。贝蒂记不清他说的是什么了。接着贝蒂打了劳伦斯。他告诉调查人员：“我记得他的脸。我永远不会忘记。他倒回沙发上，我又打了他一次。”
I keep remembering the fear in his face. Beatty said he couldn't recall how many times he struck Lawrence. He insisted he had not taken a weapon with him, but was certain he must have used one as his hands bore no injuries the following day. The next thing he said he remembered was running away down the street. Beatty then returned to his caravan where he quickly fell asleep. He rose early the next morning and went to a lay by near a highway to burn his clothing. He claimed he'd buried some articles of Lawrence's clothing that he had taken with him. Beatty allegedly offered to take officers to the locations, as well as along the route he'd walked from his caravan to the Haggard House.
我一直记得他脸上的恐惧。贝蒂说他记不清自己打了劳伦斯多少次。他坚信自己没有随身携带武器，但确信自己一定用了武器，因为第二天他的手上没有任何伤痕。他说他记得的下一件事就是顺着街道逃跑。随后贝蒂回到了他的大篷车，很快就睡着了。第二天清晨他早早起床，去了公路旁的一个路边休息区烧掉衣服。他声称自己埋掉了带走的劳伦斯的一些衣物。据称，贝蒂主动提出带警察去这些地点，以及他从大篷车走到哈格特家的路线。
Nothing in the confession referred to the mutilation of Lawrence's shoulder or the numbers written in ink on his hands. Beatty theorized that he'd committed the crime because he had been distraught about the recent mass shooting at Dunblane Primary School. According to the police notes, Beatty also said he felt bad about the fact that Lawrence's brothers had been considered suspects in the murder. Quote, I felt guilty because I knew they never done it. You will maybe find it hard to believe, but I wanted to go and say to the brothers and to his mum and dad that I was sorry for it. I also wanted to go to the grave to say sorry to him as if he would hear me. I wanted to tell his mum and dad who'd done it so they would know he was at peace now. When later presented with the transcribed notes of his confession, Beatty refused to sign them.
认罪记录中没有任何关于劳伦斯肩膀被肢解或手上用墨水写数字的内容。贝蒂推测，他犯下罪行是因为他对最近邓布兰小学的大规模枪击事件感到心烦意乱。根据警方记录，贝蒂还表示，他对劳伦斯的哥哥们被认为是谋杀案嫌疑人感到内疚。“我感到内疚，因为我知道他们从未做过。你也许会觉得难以置信，但我想去对兄弟俩以及他的父母说我很抱歉。我也想去他的墓前向他道歉，就好像他能听到我说话一样。我想告诉他的父母是谁干的，这样他们就知道他现在安息了。”当后来向他出示他的口供笔录时，贝蒂拒绝签字。
He remained on remand for his fire-raising charge as the Haggard investigation continued. Dozens of police officers searched the Falkirk countryside for the evidence that Beatty had allegedly burned following Lawrence's murder. Yet nothing of significance was found. The Haggard family was privately informed that there was a suspect in custody, but the news didn't break in the media until three months later in October. Larry Haggard told the Daily Record that the police in charge of the case were doing a great job, but he was reluctant to get his hopes up until the suspect was charged for Lawrence's murder. He described the earlier speculation about Dennis and John's involvement in the crime as a disgrace, adding, It was shocking what my sons went through. Knowing the person responsible was still at large meant my family have not had the chance to grieve properly. Then, on November 7, 1997, 33-year-old Brian Beatty was formally charged with Lawrence Haggard's murder and for fire-raising in the Haggard home.
随着哈格特案调查的继续，他因纵火罪继续被还押候审。数十名警察在法尔克拉克的乡村搜寻贝蒂在劳伦斯谋杀案后据称焚烧的证据。然而，没有发现任何重要的东西。哈格特家族私下被告知有一名嫌疑人在押，但这一消息直到三个月后的10月份才在媒体曝光。拉里·哈格特告诉《每日纪事报》，负责此案的警方做得很好，但在嫌疑人因谋杀劳伦斯被起诉之前，他不愿意抱太大希望。他将先前关于丹尼斯和约翰参与犯罪的猜测称为耻辱，并补充说：“我的儿子们所经历的事情太令人震惊了。知道肇事者仍然在逃，意味着我的家人没有机会好好悲伤。”然后，在1997年11月7日，33岁的布赖恩·贝蒂被正式指控谋杀劳伦斯·哈格特以及在哈格特家中纵火。
Brian Beatty entered a plea of not guilty. His trial began six months later in April 1998 at Edinburgh's High Court. John Haggard took the stand and wept as he detailed how he had discovered his brother's beaten and burning body, then desperately tried to save his life. During cross-examination, John admitted that he withheld knowledge of Lawrence's argument with Dennis for two weeks before coming clean to investigators. John described that fortnight as hellish and said he'd kept the fight a secret because he could tell the police suspected Dennis. John had wanted to protect the only brother he had left. He conceded that he found Dennis physically intimidating and had been briefly suspicious of him. However, when the prosecution asked whether he thought Dennis was capable of the crime, John replied, Not really. If it was just a fight or something, you could understand. But what actually happened to Lawrence? No way.
布赖恩·贝蒂做出了无罪抗辩。六个月后的1998年4月，他的审判在爱丁堡高等法院开始。约翰·哈格特走上证人席，详细讲述了他是如何发现弟弟遭到殴打并燃烧的尸体，然后拼命试图挽救他的生命，期间他失声痛哭。在交叉盘问中，约翰承认他隐瞒了劳伦斯与丹尼斯争吵的事情两周，之后才向调查人员坦白。约翰将那两周描述为人间炼狱，并表示他把这场争吵保密是因为他能看出警方在怀疑丹尼斯。约翰想保护他唯一剩下的弟弟。他承认他觉得丹尼斯在体格上很有威慑力，并曾短暂怀疑过他。然而，当控方问他是否认为丹尼斯有能力犯下罪行时，约翰回答说：“不太会。如果只是一场打架什么的，你还可以理解。但劳伦斯实际遭遇了什么？绝不可能。”
Dennis Haggard was now 14 years old. Before he began his testimony, the judge cautioned him that he wasn't required to answer any questions that might incriminate him. Following prodding from the defense, Dennis described a fight that he'd had with Lawrence several weeks before the murder. On that occasion, Lawrence had thrown a dart at his younger brother's leg, which pierced his skin. The defense suggested Dennis murdered Lawrence in revenge, quote, You were not the same kind of star at football, and that was why you burned his legs because you were jealous and angry. Dennis was adamant that he hadn't, telling the court that he had been proud of Lawrence. Detective Gordon Munro told the court of Brian Beatty's confession, which the defense was firmly rejecting. The document had been penned by police while Beatty was in custody, and he'd refused to sign it.
丹尼斯·哈格特现在14岁了。在他开始作证之前，法官提醒他，他没有义务回答任何可能自证其罪的问题。在辩方的敦促下，丹尼斯描述了他在谋杀发生前几周与劳伦斯发生的一场争吵。那一次，劳伦斯向他弟弟的腿扔了一支飞镖，刺破了他的皮肤。辩方暗示丹尼斯为了报复而谋杀了劳伦斯：“你在踢足球方面没有他那样出色，这就是你烧他腿的原因，因为你又嫉妒又愤怒。”丹尼斯坚称他没有这么做，并告诉法庭他一直为劳伦斯感到骄傲。侦探戈登·芒罗向法庭讲述了布赖恩·贝蒂的供词，辩方对此坚决拒绝。这份文件是警方在贝蒂被拘留期间撰写的，而他拒绝签字。
They maintained that their client was in Edinburgh from about 11pm to 2am the night of Lawrence Haggard's murder. However, a man who lived in the caravan next to Beatty's contradicted this claim. He said that he'd heard Beatty return home in his car between 10 and 11 that night, and didn't hear the car's engine again. When he went outside at 1.30am to dispose of some rubbish, the vehicle was in its usual parking spot. Brian Beatty told the court that the police had concocted his entire confession. He alleged that they had beaten him and used his nephews as leverage by threatening to put them into care and alleged that Beatty was molesting them. He said that he'd never admitted to the murder and had refused to sign the transcribed confession because it was entirely false. When the prosecution cross-examined Beatty, they accused him of having fantasies about abducting young men.
他们坚称他们的当事人在劳伦斯·哈格特被谋杀当晚晚上11点到凌晨2点左右都在爱丁堡。然而，住在贝蒂大篷车隔壁的一名男子反驳了这一说法.他说，他听见贝蒂当晚10点到11点之间开车回家，之后再也没有听到汽车引擎声。当他在凌晨1点30分出去倒垃圾时，那辆车停在它平常的停车位上。布赖恩·贝蒂告诉法庭，警方捏造了他整份供词。他指控他们殴打了他，并以将他的侄子送进福利机构并指控贝蒂猥亵他们作为筹码来威胁他。他说他从未承认过谋杀，并拒绝在打印好的供词上签字，因为那是完全虚假的。当控方交叉盘问贝蒂时，他们指控他有绑架年轻男子的幻想。
He denied this. Beatty said that he had only watched between 5 to 15 minutes of the pornographic video found in his home before switching it off because he didn't like it. During his testimony, Beatty began to sob. When asked why he was crying, he said, Because I am accused of this murder. I am not guilty. In summing up, the defense told the jury that the police had fabricated Beatty's confession because they were desperate to close the case. His lawyer told the court, The police were determined to get their man. They made up their mind they were going to solve this crime.
他否认了这一点。贝蒂说，在他家发现的色情视频，他只看了5到15分钟就关掉了，因为他不喜欢。在作证期间，贝蒂开始抽泣。当被问及为什么哭时，他说：“因为我被指控犯下了这起谋杀案。我是无辜的。”在总结陈词中，辩方向陪审团表示，警方捏造了贝蒂的供词，因为他们急于结案。他的律师告诉法庭：“警方决心抓到嫌疑人。他们下定决心要破获这起罪行。”
If police could not solve the murder fairly, then they would do it unfairly. Yes, ladies and gentlemen, the defense calls the police liars. They pointed out that the interview in which Beatty allegedly confessed had not been recorded as others had been. The prosecution stated that if the police had indeed fabricated the confession, then they were such talented actors that they should be members of the Royal Shakespeare Company. They asserted that Beatty had broken down on the stand because he was haunted by his guilt. Before the jury was dismissed for deliberations, judge Lord Thomas Dawson made it clear to them that their verdict hinged on Beatty's alleged confession. He said, Either the police officers are lying, or the accused is not telling us the truth.
如果警方无法公正地破获这起谋杀案，那么他们就会用不公正的手段来做。是的，女士们先生们，辩方称警察是骗子。他们指出，贝蒂据称招供的讯问并没有像其他讯问那样被录音。控方表示，如果警方确实捏造了供词，那么他们就是如此有天赋的演员，应该去皇家莎士比亚剧团。他们断言，贝蒂在证人席上崩溃是因为他被内疚折磨。在陪审团休庭退席进行商议之前，法官托马斯·道森勋爵向他们明确指出，他们的裁决取决于贝蒂所谓的供词。他说：“要么是警官在撒谎，要么是被告没有对我们说实话。”
The jury returned with a verdict that same day. They found Brian Beatty guilty of the murder of Lawrence Haggart and of fire-raising. The courtroom erupted in cheers and applause. In addressing Beatty, judge Dawson described his unprovoked attack brutal and ferocious. He added that Beatty's criminal history was very serious and he was an extreme danger to the public. Judge Dawson sentenced Beatty to life in prison with a minimum of 15 years. His sentence for fire-raising would run concurrently with his sentence for murder. Larry Haggart was grateful to those who conducted the renewed investigation into his son's murder.
陪审团当天就做出了裁决。他们裁定布赖恩·贝蒂谋杀劳伦斯·哈格特和纵火罪名成立。法庭爆发出一阵欢呼和掌声。道森法官在对贝蒂讲话时，将他的无端袭击描述为残酷而凶猛的。他补充说，贝蒂的犯罪史非常严重，对公众构成了极端的危险。道森法官判处贝蒂无期徒刑，至少服刑15年。他的纵火罪刑期将与谋杀罪刑期同时执行。拉里·哈格特对那些对儿子谋杀案进行重新调查的人表示感谢。
Yet he remained angry that it had taken more than two years to identify and convict Lawrence's killer. He accused Scotland police of botching the investigation by failing to verify Beatty's alibi and for not singling him out as a likely suspect based on his criminal history. Larry also stated that by focusing on Dennis as the perpetrator, the police had given Beatty a plan of defence. In the aftermath of the trial, the Haggart family lodged a civil complaint against central Scotland police. It addressed the investigation team's mishandling of the case and their poor conduct towards the Haggarts, including the persistent and baseless pursuit of Dennis as the killer. Dennis and John Haggart were awarded £20,000 in compensation. The police issued a public apology stating that the family should have received a much better performance. They were assured that the force had rectified its approach so that the same mistakes wouldn't be repeated.
然而，对于花了两多年时间才识别并定罪劳伦斯的凶手，他依然感到愤怒。他指责苏格兰警方搞砸了调查，未能核实贝蒂的不在场证明，也没有根据他的犯罪记录将他挑出来作为可能的嫌疑人。拉里还表示，通过将注意力集中在丹尼斯身上作为肇事者，警方给了贝蒂一个辩护方案。审判结束后，哈格特家族对中苏格兰警方提起了一起民事诉讼。诉讼内容涉及调查小组对案件的处理不当以及对哈格特一家的恶劣态度，包括对丹尼斯作为凶手持续且毫无根据的追查。丹尼斯和约翰·哈格特获得了2万英镑的赔偿金。警方发表公开道歉，称该家属本应得到好得多的对待。他们被保证该部队已经纠正了其方法，以便不会重复同样的错误。
Larry Haggart told BBC Scotland that he welcomed the apology, but he wanted the officers involved sacked. The mayhem they caused to the family, especially the two boys. To me, they've got off too lightly. In mid-1998, an independent inquiry was held to determine what exactly went wrong in central Scotland police's initial investigation into Lawrence Haggart's murder. Conducting the inquiry was Assistant Chief Constable James Mackay of the Tayside Police. His findings were published three months later in a document dubbed The Mackay Report. The details and outcome of the report were withheld from the public, including the Haggart family. Journalist Russell Finlay had covered the case extensively for the Sunday Mail and was intrigued as to why the report had been suppressed. But there was no avenue for him or anyone else to gain access to it.
拉里·哈格特告诉英国广播公司苏格兰频道，他欢迎道歉，但他希望涉案警官被解雇。他们给这个家庭带来的混乱，尤其是两个男孩。对我说，他们逃脱得太轻松了。1998年中期，进行了一项独立调查，以确定中苏格兰警方对劳伦斯·哈格特谋杀案的最初调查到底出了什么问题。负责调查的是泰赛德警局的助理警察总长詹姆斯·麦凯。他的调查结果在三个月后发表在一份被称为《麦凯报告》的文件中。该报告的细节和结果对公众保密，包括哈格特家族。记者罗素·芬利曾为《星期日邮报》对该案进行了广泛的报道，并对该报告被压制的原因感到好奇。但没有途径让他或任何人获取它。
Seven years later, in 2005, British Prime Minister Tony Blair passed the UK's Freedom of Information Act. This allowed members of the public to request access to information held by public authorities. Russell Finlay later wrote in his book, Acid Attack, a journalist's war with organised crime. I decided to seek a copy of the Haggart Report, so I approached Lawrence's dad Larry and submitted an application on his behalf. When it arrived, it made my blood run cold. The report revealed that in 1994, while serving time for abducting a teenage boy, Brian Beatty said he wished he'd killed his victim so that he could have escaped arrest. Social workers warned that Beatty was at high risk of reoffending, but he was released early on parole. By 1996, he had faded back into the Falkirk community.
七年后的2005年，英国首相托尼·布莱尔通过了英国的《信息自由法》。这允许公众申请获取公共机构掌握的信息。罗素·芬利后来在他的书《酸液袭击：记者与有组织犯罪的战争》中写道：“我决定寻找一份《哈格特报告》的副本，所以我找到了劳伦斯的父亲拉里，并代表他提交了申请。当它到达时，让我不寒而栗。”报告显示，1994年，布赖恩·贝蒂在因绑架一名十几岁的男孩服刑期间，曾表示他希望自己杀死了受害者，这样他就可以逃避逮捕。社会工作者警告说，贝蒂再次犯罪的风险很高，但他却提前获得假释出狱。到1996年，他又重新融入了法尔克拉克的社区。
Then, he was questioned in relation to the Lawrence Haggart case. The police accepted his alibi and he was promptly ruled out. The Mackay report confirmed that no effort was made to verify Beatty's whereabouts on the night of Lawrence's attack. Additionally, Beatty's criminal record wasn't accessed by investigators until almost a year later. It also noted that they didn't consider that the crime could have been sexually motivated. Furthermore, two officers had searched Beatty's car and caravan following the attack. They discovered a hammer and a petrol container, but disregarded them. In one of Beatty's previous attacks, he had struck a victim over the head with a glass bottle.
然后，他因劳伦斯·哈格特案受到讯问。警方接受了他的不在场证明，并迅速排除了他的嫌疑。麦凯报告证实，警方没有做出任何努力去核实贝蒂在劳伦斯遇袭当晚的行踪。此外，调查人员直到将近一年后才查阅贝蒂的犯罪记录。它还指出，他们没有考虑到这起犯罪可能具有性动机。此外，袭击发生后，两名警察搜查了贝蒂的汽车和大篷车。他们发现了一把锤子和一个汽油桶，但却置之不理。在贝蒂以前的一次袭击中，他曾用玻璃瓶击打受害者的头部。
A glass bottle was found in the Haggart's kitchen, but wasn't flagged as significant. Another potential weapon went missing when a piece of green metal was collected from the home, but never logged as evidence. The report detailed how fire investigators had examined the living room for 90 minutes immediately after the attack. This was before the area was secured and examined for crucial evidence such as finger or footprints. Then there was the discovery that detectives had faked a diary entries in relation to their investigation. The fraudulent entries were exposed by the author's habit of referring to Lawrence as the deceased prior to his actual death. The report also addressed confusion surrounding the discovery of a hammer in the Haggart's kitchen. One officer who inspected the property with a team of experts two days after the attack stated that if the hammer was on the kitchen table at the time, they would have seen it.
在哈格特的厨房里发现了一个玻璃瓶，但并未被标记为重要物证。当一块绿色金属从家中收集但从未被登记为证据时，另一个潜在武器消失了。报告详细描述了消防调查人员在袭击发生后立即对客厅进行了90分钟的检查。这是在现场被封锁并检查指纹或足迹等关键证据之前。然后是侦探在调查中伪造日记条目的发现。这些欺诈性条目因作者习惯在劳伦斯实际死亡之前称其为死者而被揭露。该报告还解决了围绕在哈格特厨房发现锤子的混乱情况。一名在袭击发生两天后与专家小组一起检查该房产的警官表示，如果当时锤子在厨房桌子上，他们就会看到它。
The Haggart house was searched nine times before Detective Sergeant Robert Beveridge said he'd stumbled across the item by chance during a visit one week after the attack. The Makai report concluded that Sergeant Beveridge was lying and had planted the hammer himself. According to Assistant Chief Constable Makai, the corrupt actions of investigating officers were intended to pin the crime on 12-year-old Dennis Haggart. Sections of the report were not released to journalist Russell Finley. These included portions dealing with a criminal probe against the officers involved in the original investigation. Only a few received any disciplinary action. The case's second in command, Detective Inspector John Bunyan, was suspended in August of 1998. He faced five charges, including two counts of discredible conduct and three charges of neglect of duty.
在侦探中士罗伯特·贝弗里奇表示他在袭击发生一周后的访问中偶然发现了这件物品之前，哈格特家已经被搜查了九次。麦凯报告得出结论，贝弗里奇中士在撒谎，并且是他自己把锤子藏在那里的。据助理警察总长麦凯称，调查人员的腐败行为旨在将罪名嫁祸给12岁的丹尼斯·哈格特。报告的部分内容没有向记者罗素·芬利公布。其中包括针对最初调查中涉案警官的刑事调查部分。只有少数人受到了纪律处分。该案的第二指挥官、侦探督察约翰·邦扬于1998年8月被停职。他面临五项指控，包括两项声誉败坏的行为和三项玩忽职守的指控。
The latter three charges were dropped after a lengthy disciplinary hearing. Inspector Bunyan was only found guilty of the two lesser offenses of discredible conduct. Detective Sergeant Robert Beveridge, the officer who planted the hammer in the Haggart's kitchen, was transferred out of the criminal investigation department, as was another sergeant. The case's former lead investigator, Detective Superintendent Jim Winning, avoided discipline by retiring from the force. Aged in his 40s, Winning cited health reasons for his early departure. Central Scotland Police had attempted to block his retirement, but were unsuccessful. Larry Haggart voiced his family's disappointment, telling the press, We have been fighting to get a bit of justice for our family for years. I just feel we haven't got it.
经过漫长的纪律听证会，后三项指控被撤销。邦扬督察仅被判定犯有两项较轻的声誉败坏罪。在哈格特厨房藏锤子的警察、侦探中士罗伯特·贝弗里奇被调离了刑事调查部门，另一名中士也是如此。该案的前首席调查员、侦探总督察吉姆·温宁通过从警队退休而避免了纪律处分。年近四十的温宁以健康为由提前离职。中苏格兰警方曾试图阻止他退休，但没有成功。拉里·哈格特表达了其家人的失望，他告诉媒体：“多年来，我们一直在为我们的家庭争取一点正义。我只是觉得我们没有得到它。”
There is somebody answerable to the way we were treated, and as far as I'm concerned, nobody has come up with the answer yet. In 2003, Brian Beatty lost an appeal against his conviction. He was denied parole in 2012 and remains incarcerated as of the release of this episode. In October 2015, one of Beatty's nephews came forward to accuse his uncle of molesting him. Michael, not his real name, told The Sun that Beatty started abusing him in 1994, when Michael was 13 years old. He would serve Michael sugary alcoholic beverages known as Alcopops, then rape him. Michael told The Sun, quote, It was so traumatic I blocked it out. It was horrific. There were hundreds of incidents over a spell of three years.
有人必须对我们受到的对待负责，就我而言，还没有人给出答案。2003年，布赖恩·贝蒂对定罪的上诉被驳回。他在2012年被拒绝假释，截至本集发布时仍在服刑。2015年10月，贝蒂的一个侄子站出来指控他的叔叔猥亵他。迈克尔（化名）告诉《太阳报》，贝蒂在1994年开始虐待他，当时迈克尔13岁。他会给迈克尔提供被称为Alcopops的含糖酒精饮料，然后强奸他。迈克尔告诉《太阳报》：“这太创伤了，我把它屏蔽掉了。太可怕了。在三年多的时间里发生了数百起事件。”
I would regularly wake up some days with no clothes on and him lying next to me. There were times where I'd be upstairs doing my homework, and he'd just come into my room and start doing stuff to me. Michael was scared that if he fought back, Beatty might start abusing his brothers instead. After Lawrence Haggert was murdered in March 1996, Beatty took Michael for a walk past the Haggert House. He told his nephew that he had killed Lawrence, and if Michael ever told anyone, then he would kill him as well. According to Michael, Beatty threatened his life on multiple occasions. He once held a razor to Michael's throat. Another time, he claimed to have a gun hidden under a bridge that he would use to kill him. After Beatty was convicted for murder, he sent Michael a letter.
我经常在某些日子醒来时身上没有衣服，而他躺在我旁边。有时我在楼上做作业，他就会直接走进我的房间开始对我做一些事情。迈克尔害怕如果他反击，贝蒂可能会转而虐待他的兄弟们。1996年3月劳伦斯·哈格特被谋杀后，贝蒂带着迈克尔散步经过哈格特家。他告诉侄子他杀了劳伦斯，如果迈克尔把这件事告诉任何人，他也会杀死他。据迈克尔称，贝蒂曾多次威胁他的生命。他曾把一把剃刀架在迈克尔的喉咙上。还有一次，他声称自己在一座桥下藏了一把枪，可以用它来杀死他。贝蒂因谋杀罪被定罪后，他给迈克尔写了一封信。
In it, he said he had naked photos of Michael. He blackmailed Michael into staying silent by threatening to release the images to his friends and family. Michael became a Royal Logistics Corps soldier, but struggled with post-traumatic stress disorder, anxiety, and maintaining employment as a consequence of the abuse. His personal relationships also suffered. He told the son, He has turned me into a nervous person. I've made bad decisions and pushed away my family. My worry is now that he gets out. I think he'll try and kill me. I'm trying to move on with my life, but it's so difficult.
在信中，他说他有迈克尔的裸照。他通过威胁要将这些照片发布给他的朋友和家人来勒索迈克尔保持沉默。迈克尔成为了一名皇家后勤部队士兵，但由于虐待，他一直在与创伤后应激障碍、焦虑和保持就业作斗争。他的个人关系也受到了影响。他告诉《太阳报》：“他把我变成了一个神经质的人。我做出了糟糕的决定，并把我的家人推开。我现在的担忧是他出来。我想他会试图杀死我。我正试图继续我的生活，但这太难了。”
In March 2016, a football tournament was held in honour of Lawrence Haggett near his hometown. More than 100 players took part. A charity auction was also held in conjunction with the event to raise funds for a local girl battling cancer. Lawrence's brother Dennis gave an interview to the Scotsman newspaper about the event. Quote, The response has been phenomenal. Thanks to social media, we have heard from people my brother played with more than 20 years ago. We've been overwhelmed by messages of support. People are just delighted to see Lawrence being remembered in this way. After Lawrence's death, his father Larry continued to be involved in football by helping to coach a youth team.
2016年3月，在他的家乡附近举办了一场为纪念劳伦斯·哈格特而举办的足球锦标赛。100多名球员参加了比赛。活动还结合举办了一场慈善拍卖会，为当地一名与癌症抗争的女孩筹集资金。劳伦斯的哥哥丹尼斯接受了《苏格兰人报》关于此次活动的采访。“反响太惊人了。多亏了社交媒体，我们收到了我哥哥20多年前一起踢球的人的消息。我们被支持的信息淹没了。人们很高兴看到劳伦斯以这种方式被人们铭记。”劳伦斯死后，他的父亲拉里继续通过帮助执教一支青年队来参与足球运动。
He told the Herald Scotland that doing so helped with his mental health. When things got too difficult, he would rewatch home movies of Lawrence playing the sport. Larry often paused the videos at moments that reminded him of happy memories with his son. Quote, I had a lot of good times. It was short, but it was a pleasure. Thanks for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他告诉《苏格兰人报》，这样做有助于他的心理健康。当事情变得太困难时，他会重新观看劳伦斯这项运动的家庭录像。拉里经常在让想起与儿子快乐回忆的时刻暂停视频。“我度过了很多美好时光。虽然短暂，但它是一种乐趣。谢谢观看。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。”